i remember being young and just learning
to shake hands you didn't know exactly
how to you know sometimes i put my hand
in backwards and just [ __ ] just
you know i put my thumb facing down and
whoever was shaking your hand didn't
know what the hell to do you know the
guy just sometimes he just
loses just he'd come out the damn closet
he didn't even know what was happening
you know just
because if you sh if you put your hand
out and just the thumb is it just
blows somebody's mind in a handshake
it's really
you can just really somebody who's just
been going through life very organized
shaking hands
you hit them with that upside down
handshake and they just [ __ ] they
can't handle it you know damn
you know they'll [ __ ] get a divorce
they don't they just don't know what's
going on
um
and then you when you're when you're
growing up handshaking is such a
man i remember when they first somebody
like will shake their hand they you know
your mom tells you shake their hand
and you don't you know
something you put your hand out that you
don't know it first and then
and then one time my dad introduced me
to somebody and the guy shook my hand so
hard
and i remember thinking all right
[ __ ]
all right boy
i'll [ __ ] punch your little kid in
the neck when i see him i just remember
just thinking i'ma you know i'm gonna
get these [ __ ] back
this [ __ ] ain't over i remember that the
guy my dad introduced me to the guy and
the guy just shook my my hand so hard
and i just remember thinking all right
[ __ ] this [ __ ] ain't over
and i had just i you know
just a lot you know so much happens in a
handshake
especially when you're learning the
ropes of handshaking
it's a crazy time for a
young fella or young woman
um
so then when you shake somebody's hand
and they do the dub when they
they do this regular handshake and then
they put their hand on top of you on the
back of your hand
and they're just running a train on your
hand with their hands it's just
it's too much you're like what i didn't
know we could do that
i thought you could only do one just the
rules keep changing you know you're like
i thought we could only do one hand and
this dude is tagging in his partner
this dang you know this guy's you know
the steiner brothers every i thought you
know it was just a
um
a cage match and he's running a damn
royal rumble on my hands
it just uh
i remember this just the slippery slopes
of shaking hands
and of learning what it was all like
that was kind of interesting to me
and then i dated a gal for a while that
would do a hard handshake and i'm like
i didn't want to introduce her to people
because i knew she'd just be rattling
them just you know just damn
just you know testing their joints every
time you freaking
introduced her to somebody she would
just test their joints it felt like
just uh
that was tough jesus i remember that
that was tough
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one